Why? You're like,
I think that's your So, you're like you've got like a weird >> my
wife is my wife. >> You've got Yeah, exactly. >> Hopefully
Turkey Tom will come through and he'll like actually do real
research on this and like fix it. >> Turkey Tom actually
does good. Yeah, he said that right. He said Turkey actually
does good video. >> I actually hear that. >> Welcome
to the tier five cyber club. Here's here's why mess is
>> because this is all mess, isn't it? It's all my mess
is hypocrite. So I have to point out why Miss Lore compared sister
to W. Yeah, because this guy's >> I'm not even saying
you're getting God rap this in chat. Isn't that awesome? Don't
you feel good? >> That's epic. >> Give me a bunch
of context. I didn't >> Are we Are we Tim Dog here? What's
What's happening?
>> No, I don't think so. But I maybe want to extend like
a little uh what do you call it? Like empathy to Adam. I don't
think he's ne not I don't think he's like necessarily harmful
enough that he needs like a video and he's he's throwed a couple
little arguments that actually kind of get me slightly back at
least
he's like doing a good job of convincing me that slop tubers
like a lot of commentary YouTubers who don't do any research
like suck enough that I don't care about their videos. What do
you >> What's he actually I don't really watch the Rob
video. I'm going to be honest. I watched like five minutes of
it and then skipped around.
>> Um what's the worst thing that happened? What's the
worst thing he's done? the worst thing he's done. Um,
it's a lot of like he's just a he's like a total apparently
apparently. >> We've actually we've actually confirmed
that he does have like a account where he does his own like free
amateur where he's getting by like black dudes and furry costumes
and [__]
>> Okay. And >> so I do think I think he's weird.
I think it warrants bullying
and
that there's nothing wrong with that. >> Yeah. Bullying
basically like social correction. Nothing should be illegal.
I think the part where he gets into trouble is he goes with the
the uh you shouldn't be in trouble for any drawn image, right?
He's like the he's doing the lolly defense and Nicholas didn't
like that. Okay. Nicholas didn't like his lolly defense. Rob
didn't like his >> We haven't I don't think we've seen
that part yet. >> Uh some of the arguments he does for
vegan Oh, he also basically does he does the Vos argument, but
he does it with animals. You you know the Vosch argument where
he says um >> yeah but the animals for an old man where
does your moral outrage come from? Where does your moral outrage
come from? >> No no no no no. I'm I don't have any I I
understand that that could be a thing. I'm saying he does another
argument which is the Vos argument of it's not it's not the child
and then uh capitalism. It's the there could be theoretically
a healthy relationship between an adult and a child that's and
it benefit both of them. He does that argument basically, but
for animals like you have an animal that has a diminished capacity
to consent and theoretically you could have a
>> dog really wants to [__] you. Your dog really
want and you just let it die. >> That's like the That's
the argument. >> That's the argument. Yeah. Yeah. >> And
it's like probably there are good arguments for why you shouldn't
even be making that argument, right? Like all of the rule util
versus utilitarian arguments or I forget there's like a what's
what's the non-rule utilitarian? There's like a there's like
another >> Yeah, I don't know. I I'm trying to think of
like how people describe this, but he basically >> as weird.
>> Yeah, it's all weird. Act utilitarian. Right. Right.
Right. Act utilitar. Yeah. So, he's like doing the the act util
argument. And it's like, yeah, probably not a good argument.
>> yeah. At the end of the day, it's just like making arguments
like, you know, it's about animals. Like, it's like it's not
like it's all about, you know, kids. I understand if you're like
really freaked out by someone making arguments kids making arguments
about animals like you eat animals get off your high horse. This
isn't that bad really is it? There's way worse happen. >> No,
no, no. There's a there's like an evolved there's an evolved
suppression for your disgust response in eating animals, right?
That kept you alive for so long.
>> It was so he was making some of those like vegan arguments,
but he's also not a vegan. Yeah, he's not even a like I thought
I thought he was like, "Oh, I love animals and you guys don't
even like animals." And then we found a video of him eating steak
with like So we thought he was vegan. It's like, "Okay, he's
like making the, "Oh, I don't want to harm animals. I'm actually
less harmful to animals than you." And no, he's just he like
actually just I don't >> He just he does this thing. He
he says there's nothing wrong with this dog or there's nothing
wrong with a horse because you do worse. It's like this hypocrisy
point like you're a hypocrite for having a problem with this
>> which both both of them are bad and neither of them
are bad. I think that's the point, right?
>> Um no, I think I think the argument is society has this
like suppression of disgust response because we ate animals to
like survive at one point and you think that we should have to
match that evolved response with like our response to and it's
like no, I can just have the revulsion decision and admit that
we should probably do better on the eating animals front and
the animal cruelty front. Well, okay. You're just saying you're
just like coming up with like an intellectualized way to say
really icky, but you actually disagree with literally what I
just said. >> He overintellectualizes
much of this. >> Both of them are bad. >> You say
it's intellectualized, but it what what do you disagree with?
>> Well, that's what I'm saying. You just said that as
if you were disagreeing with me, but you actually just said exactly
what I'm saying. Either either both of them are bad or neither
of them are. That's just >> No, I said I said actually
I said actually I'm totally fine with keeping one. I'm totally
fine with being inconsistent. I can say they're both bad, but
I'm totally fine with being inconsistent. And I think the idea
where he goes because his next argument is, and I just want consistency
here. I think wanting consistency, >> then what do you
mean? But wait, wait, but if you're fine with being No, no, because
you're saying you're fine with being inconsistent, but you're
not cuz you're saying we should try and do better on the eating
animals front. So, you're obviously not fine with being consistent.
You think we should be
>> Uh, we should be, but I'm fine with doing like moving
no direction there. And I'm fine with saying I don't want to
be I I know that it'll be tough to solve the what do you call
>> Okay. And that that's that's like a
so people say like if you live in a society and you don't have
criticisms if you're not going to be a vegan that you can't really
criticize people for [__] animals. And I just think
that's stupid. >> Well, you can't morally criticize. >> Okay.
I don't make a I don't really make a difference between a moral
criticism and me making fun of you for something that's like
totally disgusting. Like in terms of >> there is two different
weird for you to do that. I feel like I understand that there
is a intellectualized difference, but in terms of like I don't
know anything else like having a practical discussion with somebody
is just >> but that's the root of it because every time
I keep reading >> it just sounds like you're coming up
with a million different ways to just you're just coming up with
a million different ways to avoid saying >> basically that
there's a that you know one of them's like they're both okay
either. It just that that is okay but hold on avoid saying that.
The only thing that Adam does is say everybody is moral grandstanding.
You're being right. He he the idea that he's getting bullied.
The people bullying him are just implying that they are like
morally better than he is. >> Rob's media is moral grandstanding
in that video. >> Rob's media. But I'm saying everybody
else like the cuz he's he's getting >> Yeah. There's a
lot of people that would just say would just say
Yeah. Yeah. A lot of people would just say that's [__]
gross. >> But lots of people moral grandanding on >> No.
No. Of course. But but most people don't say that. Most people
go, "Oh my god, it's so wrong and and evil that someone would
think it's okay to an animal." It's like, you eat animals. What
do you mean it's so wrong and evil? That's what most people say.
Most people say, "Oh my god, it's abuse. It's evil." You you
eat animals.
Do you think there's not like a social degeneracy argument that
you're cutting against like the social >> you can make
arguments about how even about how it's antisocial and how it
it's like not behavior you should engage in because it can offput
your family and cause issues or some like this. You can make
many of those same arguments like Adam would say for being for
being gay in a time where it was not acceptable to be gay too.
But regardless, you can make those arguments and uh you know
you can be homophobic and justify it. >> Yeah. But you
just want to you just want to come here and have the argument
versus like the the weakest version of it. You're going to say
everybody just thinks, "Oh, you're so
>> Evil [__] dogs." >> Shouldn't there
be some ratio of utility to like social deviency that needs to
be like respected? Like basically people are just engaging like
the >> [__] Okay. So is it okay to be gay when
people are against gay people? I just I say probably it's actually
arguably like not necessarily depending on how bigoted the society
is, right? To to start advocating for this, right? Like you're
you're probably causing like some amount of social harm to people
be people who get stoned, right? >> So I mean you can have
that perspective, but it's not most people's perspective. You
know, most people think we should have social progress and so
they're not going to like a system that >> that a system
should be. I said there should be a ratio, right? like is in
>> everyone adopt if everyone adopt the system there's
more movement. >> What if a thousand years from now it's
actually okay to like eat your young and that's totally but like
right now I don't think you should advocate just because some
at some future point we've progressed to the point where we actually
we understand that like oh you know before a certain age you're
below a certain cognitive threshold and >> is that harmful
now? Is that harmful now? Holy sh. But I I feel like the the
whole thing with being gay at a time where it wasn't accepted
is you actually you accepted and you acknowledged why certain
people stayed in the closet out of fear, right? Because they
were going against the social norm. And you also acknowledged
the heroism or I think that's a word that you would use for people
who spoke out and were proudly gay and would explain why it was
fine to be gay. They didn't do >> Okay, you guys. This
is a very kind of lame conversation cuz I feel like you guys
have just tried to come up with, oh, here's how I justify being
disgusted by this. It's like
>> justifying I am disgusted.
I am disgusted by it. >> You're just going to say that
over and over again as if it's making a good >> You're
mad that I just don't think oh
you're not arguing anything cuz you're you've got your argument
like you're just like
>> I can't get one out. I literally I can barely speak.
I can't even get through a full sentence before English. Well,
because because Jay- Sock is helping you, okay, by cutting me
off, the person who's making the >> argument. Go ahead.
Go ahead. >> Yeah. If if you stop chiming in after I make
a good point, then he can respond. >> Okay. Go ahead. >> I'm
waiting for Quan to respond. That's a lot of time. >> I
don't know. I don't know what point you I didn't know what I
was responding to. I thought you were going to go. I
>> Okay. You're making the argument that like, oh, the
the response to him is that it's evil that you're dogs or it's
evil that you want to dogs. Uh, no. Oh, I'm not saying that.
I think it's gross. >> No, that's >> Well, I'm not
a lot of people, so you have to actually engage with what I'm
saying, right? >> Well, I don't have anything to engage
with there. I just I agree. Yeah, it's gross for dogs, and it's
kind of weird to bring up how you how it should be okay to dogs.
I agree with that. There's no argument there. >> Oh, okay.
So, you don't even agree with Adam? What the are you doing?
>> Well, no. I I'm saying about Rob's media's video,
that was moral grandstanding from what I saw. And most of the
response Adam gets is moral grandstanding. So of course when
he's going to respond when he's responding to criticism that
is how he's responding to it. He's he's arguing it. He's saying
well how are you going to get on a moral high horse about this
when you eat meat when you support you know like cows getting
[__] for milk you know. >> And I I've already
said it's it's >> Yeah. You could talk to now cuz he's
clearly just pretending to be >> it's his argument. It's
his uh like uh what do you call it? act utilitarian argument
around animals,
right? Which is probably the the assailable thing that even arguing
>> that's the one you would Yeah. >> Yeah. Well,
I mean >> I already said I didn't I I already said I didn't
even >> dis then you're saying then you're saying oh we
can't have certain conversations. I feel like most people wouldn't
agree with that either. I thought if someone actually argued
that most people would >> you can have the conversation
but you have to deal with you have to deal with how everybody
else like handles it and not obviously
and posted a bunch of YouTube threads and absolutely luck out
over over this thing. Well, yeah, sure. But that's not really
uh
responding to any point he's making. That's just saying, "Wow,
you're really embarrassing yourself, bro."
>> I I responded to the act utilitarian point he made.
>> Yeah, but No, no, no. You're saying you probably shouldn't
have these types of conversations. I thought you were saying
that was like a real utilitarian thing you were saying is that
you shouldn't even have these types of conversations because
of the negative outcome. >> I'm saying that it's pretty
just it's pretty like uh you can have the conversation, but he
believes that, right? and he gives like a full on fullthroat
defense for why he believes it. He says, "I'm attracted to Scar
and I would never a real lion." So obviously I can understand
like why somebody could blah blah blah blah blah blah blah. And
then he's like, "Oh, and also >> there's there's a couple
other things that go along." Sorry, I actually just gave the
wrong point. But he's um
>> he basically gives like his point. He's like, I understand
how you could be attracted to only certain features, but I also
understand like
he gives the the like uh what do you call it that I think his
argument is dolphins try to people and obviously there's some
agency and consent on the part of the dolphin >> Yeah.
Wait, I I heard I heard through Chudstream I heard in his response
him talking about animal consent. I mean that there is obviously
some kind of
like form of consent in the animal kingdom that's not human consent.
Is that do you not agree with that? Animals can consent to each
other. Do you think you should meet that same bar? Do you think
you can actually meaningfully have like match that? >> No,
I thought he he said that you can't. I thought he said that he
doesn't think humans can have consensual relationships with animals
in this in this response
>> in he he says they can't have informed consent, but
you can have the same consent an animal would have with another
animal. That's what he says. >> Yeah, that's >> he
says you can't have informed consent. Yeah. I don't think >> that's
what you were saying with um >> the Voch argument where
well there's a percentage chance >> the act argument. Yeah.
>> So okay dolphin
>> rap a woman or what? What is okay dolphin a woman versus
woman like? What's the what's the difference here with the dolphin's
consent?
>> There is no difference with the dolphin's consent. But
if you if you there's one wrong increased capacity to entice
the dolphin to you, right? There's something going on there that
I mean it's a non-consensual it's a non-consensual act if the
dolphin pins you down to raise you in the water, right? Like
you don't have >> Yeah. Yeah. But let's say let's say like
you know
the dolphin like looks like it's coming over and the woman's
like I wouldn't mind getting by dolphin and just kind of let
it happen. What what is the what is the moral uh is that wrong?
Uh, is it morally wrong? If the woman Yeah. If the woman assumes
that if the woman thinks the dolphin's coming over to Yeah, I
think so. I think that's probably wrong. >> I don't think
she's >> because of the state of mind
>> or because of the inaction. >> Yeah, there's like
a there's like an example somebody gave of like if you go to
the army and you say, "I want to sign up because I just want
to kill a bunch of brown people." They probably go, "Yeah, actually
we don't want you." But realistically, their their mission is
to go and kill a bunch of brown people,
>> Yeah. But we wouldn't say >> there's something
in your state of mind there where it's like >> if you join
the army if you if you join the army because you want to bunch
of brown people
you're probably a person but just in that you haven't done something
wrong >> and the woman who's baiting the dolphin is a >> wait
what I person >> they're a non person no I'm saying she's
>> what we're talking about but what I'm saying is I'm
distinguishing being a [__] person you haven't done
anything wrong yet as a as as the the racist person joining the
army just like you know I I don't like at what point does the
wrong action occur with the woman who allows rape >> people
um I would say as you form the like intent to not evade the dolphin
as you like get into the water knowing it could have like there's
there's something building there right >> it's the it's
the it's and the other thing about the human relationships is
you can't really trust these people to like have the animals
best interest at heart when they're trying to get something else
out of that relationship. So, they're an increased capacity.
They're at an increased like capacity to consent, right? It's
just like you wouldn't I don't know >> like they're looking
for signals that aren't there. >> Not letting a babysit
your like daughter or something, right? For this exact reason
like they might not actually be hateful, but it's like there
is just some some amount of
>> I I would not like retit 100%. I'm with I'm with you
on that part. But I just don't know in like if you're using utilitarianism,
I don't know how you disting what
where is the wrong act between why why is being by a dolphin
you're doing >> the inability to pick the >> I mean
I suppose you of it not being a
>> I'm sure I Well, yeah. I'm not saying you know this
isn't like >> Yeah. I don't know where the line is.
I think there's probably like uh like you'd have to delineate,
right, some some decision where they they know that this might
happen with the dolphin and they have the ability to like pull
away, right? So they're not getting >> how how much effort
do you have to put in in trying to get away from the dolphin
before you're doing something
>> Can you go back to the Avatar? That's just you.
>> Yeah, sure.
Uh I can also change the topic or we can just finish Adam's video.
No, you if you and Creman like doing this, I'm going to like
go clean or something. >> Yeah. I don't like overall
having this conversation for like a certain period of time is
just like feel like we're just, you know,
>> cuz I feel like I've made all the good arguments cuz
we J and I started talking about this before we even started
streaming. Um >> I gave all of your arguments by the way,
Quean, when I talked about it before we started streaming. >> I
already knew. >> I can run through. It's the easiest thing
in the world if you've watched Destiny as much as you have or
even almost as much as I have. Like uh you can run through the
vegan animal versus arguments like all day very easy. >> I
already know I'm not going to agree with Queen on this. Okay.
I'm I'm surprised he will give me as much to say, yeah, I would
bully somebody who has with animals cuz he does do the debate
lord for this and for like the lolly stuff. >> Why am I
bully them? Like it's it's funny to bully them sometimes, but
then sometimes it's also funny to like ironically support, if
you know what I >> I know you are a >> you're special.
>> The big thing about this response is I think he just
lays out where Furio and Rob's media are super disingenuous like
multiple times
and that's I'm like, you know what, let's go. I love it. >> Yeah.
I feel like, you know, I >> going to defend Adam just >> just
because he's against Dioro. Like I said, I saw like five minutes
of the original Rob video and I saw like
20 minutes I want to say of Chud watching this response.
Um, and I I heard about Dior being involved. I was like, "Wow,
I know that coverage is probably abysmal." I I can just imagine
being like nails on
>> Unfortunately, Adam's very very stuck on defending himself
over how wrong it is to shame people on stuff like this. Like
he's like, "Listen, Nicholas Dioro was just telling me, "Yes,
yes, I should feel shame for like being a furry." And I've I've
archived the stream, by the way. He can't even delete it now.
It's like, dude, I think he's going to be fine with letting that
opinion hang out there. Okay. >> He's like very convinced
that that's like a winning argument for him. These guys are shaming
me as [__] up. >> And Kumman, you would love
this because like Adam just puts out this uh almost 2hour video
uh defending himself. Big effort post the next day.
Uh, Dioro clips a portion. I don't know if it's it's from like
an old stream of his, an old clip of Adams and makes a point
about him and and Adam's like, "I could tell you didn't watch
any of my video because I explained this in that." And it's like,
"Oh, yeah, buddy. Did you put something out that's two hours
long?" "Yeah, Dorio is not reading it. He's just against you.
I'm not watching it. He's just against you." I love that combination.
>> Yeah, Dorio. Uh, that guy sucks. Is this uh Perry's
in the waiting room? I'm seeing Perry is really upset about this
movie thing. >> I literally
>> if he couldn't just join. So I I literally give him
perms to join.
But maybe I could just move him. Give him like two seconds to
join on his own. >> He like messaged you in my Discord
apparently and was like, >> "No, I know this is going to
be one of those animal." >> Do you want me to You want
me to switch your avatar out?
>> I don't know an animal.
What the hell? No, >> he's against YS. He's against YS.
No, >> I'm against you cuz you're such an obvious hypocritical
piece of where it's like, oh, well, I miss obviously in the wrong
for trying to censor Rob's media. Well, I don't like Rob's media,
so I guess that's aok. Okay. I guess that's a okay. So, >> when
did I ever say that? When did I ever say that? >> Well,
you did in your actions. You said in your actions. That's how
you said. >> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
I think is it not a valid censoring of Rob's media if Rob's media
is like directing people to his and like uh describing his like
wellensor
>> Chud wait Chud totally gets by that stuff or has gotten
by that stuff right you got reading the Vos DMs >> I I
got a video I got my stream taken down reading the Destiny leaks
dude like >> I said that >> yeah you can't do crazy
content on >> well it's not crazy content it's like that's
how YS wants to portrayed It's just a picture of him in a horsesuit
or even a horsesuit and he does the game
that picture. Was it just that picture? >> It was just
that picture. Well, it was that picture and the picture that's
why I miss uses for his profile picture which is obviously which
is obviously like unccropped and that causes it. You'd see a
guy with like a >> you know for sure that's what got it
>> Well, no. I don't know for sure what it is. I don't
know what's for sure got 18 plus. No. >> Wait, is that
what he said was wrong with the video? Um, I don't even know
if he said that's what's wrong, but that's what why I messed
up what was wrong with the video is that he was like going out
of his way to direct people towards my when it's like um, why
messed us? Why mess that? Why mess NSFW channel all the >> Was
it Wait, wait, wait. Okay, Perry, is that the only thing he complained
about was people directed to directing to her >> for the
video? I mean, as far as um, why videos against us? That is my
understanding of it. Yes. Uh, >> did he not talk about
how there was like graphics detail in the video?
>> Um, did he talk about how there's graphics detail in
the video? Well, he did that in his vocal response in his >> No,
I think he did that in like one of his tweets or his YouTube
comment beforehand as well. Barry, >> I don't think it
was in the YouTube com. Okay. Well, if it's in YouTube, but he
didn't. It wasn't video. >> It was either that or the tweet.
It was either that or the tweet. I >> think he I'm pretty
sure he said that >> He put it in his YouTube comments
back to their videos. >> Oh, maybe the comments to the
videos. I was thinking about the comments he posted in the tweets.
Yeah. Regardless, it wasn't vivid and I listened to it. It wasn't
vivid and unless every time says
that's that means that unless that's like against US, which obviously
isn't. >> Okay. What do they what did Rob actually say?
What did Rob media actually say? >> He described the avatar
of YMS, the female horse furry avatar persona getting in the
by Scar. It's at least one of them. Another one of Scar getting
the ass by a >> He said that's why has porn with a black
man. I think that part. >> Yeah. Also, YMS getting gangbanged
by two black bulls.
>> spit roasted baby. I actually don't know. Didn't get
quite that gra. >> I mean, I don't I just don't Is it really
that crazy for that video to get age restricted? >> It's
crazy for Yms to hypocritically tell his audience, basically
get his audience to like mass flag uh Rob's media. So, it is
hypocritical and it's critical for you to defend that. >> Okay,
I'm I haven't defended anything. What What What is uh
>> What is hypocritical about
the act of complaining about that being in the video? What has
YMS done? Is >> um YMS is literally pro bulimia. Literally
made his career on being an edgy furry. Every end of his videos
is look at me and my furry friends. They actually do. I am literally
describing to you what he's done. He's entire >> But no,
actually
>> how are so many people unaware of his uh his account
if he did that? >> Um how are people weren't unaware of
his porn account. It was well known. I knew about this when I
was like 13. Okay. This guy went around all the time like, "Hey
guys, today we're going to review Today we're going to review
uh After Earth." Anyway, check out my uh epic uh reaction. Adam,
>> I think I see. So, you're like you've got like a weird
rule.
>> No, because of YMS. But he's innocent somehow. But he's
innocent somehow. I'm sincerely actually upset because this guy
I'm telling you videos >> Perry Perry can you just tell
me a furry
>> cognto hazard like are you are you
>> I mean just listen to my voice isn't it kind of like
self-evident anyway the point is at the end of this guy's old
video reviews okay at the end of this guy's old video reviews
he would always do this thing where it's like check out my react
channel to my gaming friends and like he would do like a clip
right to preview it and the clip would be have you heard of nodding
have you heard of nodding oh it's like when you get alien and
they do like weird orgasm noises And this was all not 18 plus
allowed on his channel. So YMS is more than okay with doing EPI.
But now somebody criticized him. Oh, that's evil. That's evil.
Mass reported video. That's a hypocrisy. >> So the hypocrisy
is he was putting in his main channel videos teasers to react
videos or whatever where >> not just that. Not just that.
He would do probalia content where he teaches his child audience
how to vomit on command. He would do like a bunch of referencia
content. How was it probable content? >> He would teach
his literally teach his audience how to vomit. literally teaches
audience how >> Y did he
that was that laugh yeah an >> on a video made available
to children Yms literally said it used to be available it's not
anymore yms literally said hey guys this is how you vomit on
command this how you vomit on command right to a video that would
be >> direct is all the other stuff still available is
all the other stuff
>> also in the context in that context was it like so they
could be bimic or was it just about vomiting on command for some
of the context >> no but if blue listen if bluey made a
[__] video. If Blue made a episode about how to Bob
on command, I would find an issue with that. But you guys are
just okay with it. If this guy can make videos which are interesting
to children, then I think you should hold him accountable is
the way he's holding video accountable. But I guess you're okay
with hypocrisy. Anyway, the other content is available on his
child, but the probable stuff got age restricted, but still available.
But then he used to age restricted, but stuff isn't age restricted.
So, but I guess you said nice one, so I'm just wrong automatically
somehow. Okay. So, I mean it sounds like the teasers for his
other channel. That sounds hypocritical. That sounds bad. >> It's
not just that. Even in the content of his channel, even God of
his channel, he'd be like he showed some of the pictures literally
not the furry, not the horse furry, but he showed some of the
pictures that he complain. Well, he implicitly complains about
Rob's media showing in his other videos. He like talks about
this stuff all the time. Um I don't know, maybe like in the last
few years. Also, the Nicholas Dioro clip I feel like is a good
example where he's like literally doing the exact same thing
that he's criticizing Rob Media for where he is like directing
people to E621 for Predator.
Like literally like showing like his edi he says his editor did
it. So >> I don't know what I actually have no idea what
you're in this response. He also says that yeah you know what
I'm just uh >> he said something like oh yeah just so you
know like I'm probably a hypocrite here. Yeah, I get to be a
hypocrite but it doesn't matter. It's like yeah.
>> Oh. Oh, if it doesn't matter, well, you got to me. >> But
he's saying that like basically he's not the person who first
got aggressive. He's not the person who like first did this.
And like he's censored most of his in a way that like it's not
even >> Except that clip. Well, except it's not. It's actually
I would say that like uh >> Jason, how do you feel about
that response? How respons
>> uh the response is good. He's just um I think he doesn't
want to give up any of the arguments. And I think you're just
gonna be called like a total weirdo for not giving up any of
the arguments, but he he points out like a lot of the
>> Like I have no idea why Rob's media brought up the fact
that he gave uh what was it? Not Road to Elorado. He gave some
movie Oh, the >> Oh yeah, it was >> Prince of Egypt
four out of 10 or something because he hates Christians. And
it's like wait, why is that relevant to any of this? >> Yeah,
that was stupid. It's not really relevant. It's a shitty video.
>> Well, because any And I guarantee I haven't heard much
that much of his response. Uh from the little bit I have heard,
I feel like he has correctly clocked that Rob's media is not
interested in making uh YouTube drama videos and he's not interested
in making uh like journalistic pieces. He's not interested in
like any of that. Rose Media is interested in making uh gay
uh like covert conservative propaganda because he's a disgusting
>> tur slop but like >> disgenic as I think I think
the the one thing I can latch on to to feel like he's not a complete
like genetic anomaly
>> it's latching on to his you know 20% white identity
and
>> I can get clean to turn on YMS right now by the Okay,
I I can just mention how Yms is like, "Oh my god, I guess I'll
just need like hopefully Turkey Tom will come through and he'll
like actually do a real research on this and like fix Tom actually
does good." Yeah, he said that, right? He said Turkey actually
does good video assist. >> I actually did hear that. I
actually did I actually did hear him say that. Yeah, this guy
face the wall. Face the wall. >> But you're defending that's
your guy. It's your guy. And you think this video should be >> and
Turkey should take his channel own channel. That's what you think.
>> No, I don't believe that. I don't believe that. I think
uh I'd rather Robs media had has his little corner, you
>> I could say to me like the uh >> Yeah. The thing
is Turkey Turkey Tom would defend Adam if he was still friends
with Destiny, but now Turkey Tom has no reason to take it easy
on some of the degenerates and stuff like that. So he won't
>> was that a thing. >> Yeah, it was defin I mean
it was definitely he definitely went easy on Destiny 100%. >> Destiny
documentary
>> and Adam and Destiny like hung out I think a few times,
right? So I mean
Destiny has Adam's Destiny has Adam's first ever keyboards that
he made all his albums on. He basically gave him a childhood
heirloom that Adam gave Destiny a childhood heirloom. So whenever
you see the keyboard that Destiny like stories out on in the
background, that's actually Adam's keyboard that he wrote his
furry songs on. This is a real thing.
>> I hate that I know that you're wrong.
>> I am right. What I'm telling
the keyboard I hate that I know that much that I know that you're
wrong >> because if Adam definitely gave him one. >> Yeah,
I know he did. And then before
>> before Steven moved to Miami, he gave that one away.
>> He gave that a viewer came to his apartment and picked
up the keyboard. >> There's no way he gave away like the
>> Was that a special keyboard? >> That's insane
autism. If he did that, >> I thought he gave away his keyboard
and then why gave him his keyboard. If Dusty gave away YMK, that's
epic. Hey, here's this likely heirloom that this guy kept it
to me.
>> Maybe maybe
somebody fact checked me. Someone who knows more than me. That's
>> Text, welcome to the tier five summer clubber. Here's
here's my message.
>> It I'm pretty sure it was a fan who just came over and
picked it up.
>> I could be wrong. That does that's funnier. So, I believe
it's that's >> Sound like something that could be possible
that he would just have no emotional understanding of what that
meant. And like, yeah, he gave me this keyboard and how now it's
yours. Go >> I'm moving now. I'm moving. You know, it's
hard to pack. Mina has all of uh my plugs. I mean, her plugs.
Uh, got to go.
>> What did you guys think of the empathy argument Adam
made? He's he's like uh he he rejected his identity as a furry
for years. It drove him to crystal meth. Okay. And only through
accepting his identity as a furry was he able to overcome his
his substance abuse problems.
And so he tries to be accepting of other fries. He thinks it's
really wrong to socially shame them. What do you guys think of
that? >> He shames the cool cat guy. So he's a hypocritical
piece of you know cool cat guy. Pull up this guy's channel. Pull
up. Why am I cool cat review? This guy's just making fun of man.
This guy's aable piece of y
>> diversions that like >> this is all [__]
mess isn't it? It's all mess is a hypocrite. So I have to point
out why l you're autistically obsessed with why mess. No, because
this >> I'm not even saying you'reically obsessed, Perry.
I'm saying you're sending us off on random diversions that >> you
think about why am I saying he's
>> Just had an epic destiny rant right there. Can we acknowledge
that epic destiny rant? >> Yeah, that was a minus five.
Perry minus >> No. Shouldn't be a multiple of two though.
Has a minus. It would be minus four. No. Or -6. Whatever. >> It
was $5 per destiny of them. >> Thought it was $2. Anyway,
whatever. Um
the point is YBS is such a piece of man and the fact that you
queen are enabling this guy to do the this is against us. I thought
you were against that kind of
you're getting rap this in chat. Isn't that awesome? Don't you
feel good? >> That's epic. I didn't even know God was on
kick. That's awesome. J.
>> No. No. Perry, don't let them distract you. You stop
letting enable this guy. >> They're sweeping for iOS. >> Yeah,
they are. They are. It's
>> You need to need to make complaints about my people
like less mentally disabled. I think because when you just come
on and start saying I'm just promia, it's like really gay and
>> He is promia. Pull up. Okay. So, >> it's really
gay and annoying when you try and get
We're not We're not pulling up the cool cat thing either cuz
that doesn't say the thing you said it said either. So, >> you
So, you know, so you're a secret Ys grooming victim too. >> I've
watched y
videos. >> So, you know that. Okay. So, you're like your
power level. >> I like this neopre. I like this brain
>> Hey, look at this wacky guy. >> Hold on, Perry.
I'm going to help you out here. Okay. Why do you think bad empanada
is so cool when he just makes things up about people, but when
Perry does it, you make fun of him? >> Because he's afraid
of bad empanada. Because bad panada looks like scarier physically.
That's literally us.
>> I think it's bad. Bad panado works it like, you know,
it's close enough to the truth and he'll throw in like one insane
telling the truth. tell you the truth. >> It's a promise.
>> It'll like either be a very tightly woven lie or a totally
insane lie that you believe that someone will believe cuz they've
been primed for it. You know, like saying, >> "Are you
works in >> like Yeah, exactly. subtle things about how
Will's content's changed. It's not all quite true. Like he he
didn't just start doing like pro Israel stuff like he's been
doing it against since the Ukraine stuff started and all this."
So, it's not really true that he just started shilling Israel
at the moment. You know, he he got the opportunity to. >> It
does seem like the furry dude who went to a furry convention
with a bunch of drugs and people in diapers for fun might be
into
throwing up and watching people throw up.
>> No, he's not into it. He wants to He literally made
a tutorial for it, man. Literally made a tutorial for it. It's
even worse.
>> I'm slightly hiding my power level cuz I actually have
seen you talk about the blamia thing already and I know it's
the gag.
so you're going to tell me quick. You're going to tell me that
Rogers came out here. If Mr. Rogers came out here and was like,
"Hey kids, today we're going to learn about the dopamine you
can get from your wrists." You're telling me that I would be
ethical for Mr. Rogers to do, right? Because it's just a gag.
Just a gag. >> So, Perry, it's a gag where he's escaping
from a child and a video for kids and a video for kids and a
video for kids. A gag and a video for kids.
It's not a video for kids. >> It is a video for kids. So
is entertainment for kids. So is entertainment for kids. It was
unrestricted for a decade. Yeah. >> Wait. So age restriction
where I live.
>> Well, it has an age restriction, but it was on YouTube,
not age restricted. So imagine you're a kid and you're in horror
movies. You would obviously watch the YMS review because you
can't actually watch the movie. So he's basically creating a
kids replacement for Saw. >> Look up Spongebob Saw right
now. Look up Spongebob Saw right now. >> No, I'm not. I'm
good. Spongebob Saw. >> You got your arguments. >> Yeah.
Look up Spongebob playing Saw. I'm going to link it to you. Jay
Stok. I'm going to link it to you.
>> I'm going to link it to you. >> We're going to
skip over Queen admitting that he pre-watched all of Perry's
>> That's all he
I clicked on his stream and he was literally seething about me
by name. So I I clicked So I clicked around to watch the next
three hours.
Queen just clicks around live stream on YouTube until he hears
something close to his name and then he's like, "Oh, there's
the content. Okay, let me >> I don't I don't I genuinely
I have I have borderline stopped watching Harry talk about me
almost because of that uh instant that and the past
just the fact that you thought that that admission was like consequential
is crazy to me. I almost stopped watching Perry talk about me
at this point.
>> I I I have not watched Perry's Plastic Mage segment
because of >> Cuz you're afraid of it. You're afraid that
I will win and you are such a Jason. Give us the girls plastic
beach. This is important. Okay. >> I have no idea. It's
not going to be >> Not doing this whole argument here.
It's just like it's so dumb. >> Got a bit
>> but like seriously like unironically like the fact that
Y would be like I don't know. Is this to you? I don't know. It's
like behavior and fact you're sweeping for it is annoying. >> But
how am I sweeping for it? >> You're like soft enabling
him. You're being like
this guy's pro blaming. This guy's pro. You refused you refused
to talk about your stream. Literally ran from this. You I asked
you about this topic. You're like, I don't care about this. Spend
an hour on [__] talking about it. >> Yeah,
cuz I can argue cuz I like arguing about it. I like arguing about
like the beastiality arguments and [__] That's fine.
But I don't like >> Yeah, I like I like to spend Okay,
so just right now say why is a piece of trying to take Rob M's
channel down. >> I haven't looked into it enough, but yeah,
he probably sucks.
>> Uhhuh. Well, I mean
is probable. Maybe he thinks more people should be throwing him.
>> Did you get to the part where YMS says I'm a submissive?
I can't get off on this. Everyone has consent. Did you get the
part where he's basically enabling >> unless somebody wants
somebody
isn't you cannot pressure you cannot. Okay. Yeah. He's insinuating
consent though. He's insinuating. >> He said something
weird about if they're
>> No, no, no. That was uh >> It wasn't >> that
was a diminished capacity thing. He was like, >> "Oh, uh
if it's if the dog isn't in pain." And then we were talking about
the loop.
>> Like I was like, "Oh, well, if they're sleeping, you
have a lot of lube. They won't feel pain or something like he
brought up stress or something." Yeah. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. He's making weird arguments about >> which
is something that Diddy had done. There was like one person that
had to go to the hospital and I think that person used it to
blackmail or to get money out of him. And since then,
Diddy's
freakoffs or whatever like that always included a whole bunch
of lube in Astroglide according to >> Rob's Media's physio.
Can we pull up pull up Rob Rob's phys? >> What does he
look like? >> Rob and where is the photo of him with Sam
Hyde? I thought you said that. >> Rob's media's Lego review
right now. Rob picture was with Sam Hyde.
Rob's media died on Twitter. Lego Rob's media Lego review >> response
we get images Rob's media Sam Hyde Sam Sam Hyde with Rob's Is
this Rob's media
>> you're sweeping by not pulling up >> Rob's media
by the way >> what do you what do you hate about this guyman
tell me what you hate about this guy oh that beard is not good
that beard is not
>> look at the physiography here is this
>> this is like pure like this is like strength in the
pipe this is like
>> pull up Adam Yms. Pull up Adam Yms
and do a side by side. >> How do I get How do I get the
higher res version of this >> open image in it? Didn't
it didn't it didn't work. This works though.
>> You just know this guy smelt like in high school, bro.
>> Just in high school. >> Yeah, that that beard
is cataclysm. Why Why is he letting it grow out that long
>> Um he's doesn't like feeling his face,
>> dude. This is like Yeah. This guy. You can't grow any
beard above your like jawline.
Give it up. >> Don't grow a beard. Yeah. Axe. >> Don't
grow the complete neck beard. >> Suffer suffer with whatever
optenic jaw and chain you've got. Okay. No hiding >> and
long hair. No. >> Hold on. You get saved by like by like
just like some stubble. Like you you just shave it close. >> You
have to totally shave it off. You >> have to Yeah.
>> You wouldn't like me when I'm angry, if you know. like
12 millimeters of length there or something. It's not good.
>> He has the gay aviator glasses as well and the dandruff
hair and the Neanderl. >> You guys are so mean.
>> Well, it's fine cuz me and Rox media go way back and
um this guy's a won't debate YS. Did you know that? He can but
won't debate Yms. >> Wait, is YMS offered to debate and
he's he's ducking?
>> No way.
the video.
>> He says that it would be bad content cuz YMS is just
like uh >> Dude, what? Oh my god, he's such a leaking to
be fair to um to be fair, but I think it's obvious. >> You're
leaking DMs. You're leaking DMs right now. >> Yeah, I'm
licking DMs right now. >> Okay, can you can you just say
say this from the start to the finish for a club?
>> Um, no.
>> Wait, just explain what's happening, Barry, please.
Um, my uh Rob's media uh refuses to debate why I mess because
he says, "Yeah, I left him on red. I don't know him a comment
pin if he's going to spend said comment calling me a groomer
20 times. I said in my original video, I hate to waste the time
engaging with him because he's not going to change his opinions.
His tactic is to bog you down with drawn out responses instead
of giving simple answers." Nick Dioro linked his DMs with Adam
and they were massive walls of text from Adam's end. I said,
"Okay, I think it would be good content if you debated him though."
And then he responds, "It would, but it wouldn't be worth a wild
discussion. He's too much of a spur in a bad empada sort of way."
So there you go, >> dude. What is in a bad empada sort
of way? He hasn't dogs anyone. This is the most excuse going.
It is not about whether you're going to change his opinion. It's
about whether your arguments stand up to scrutiny. You
same situation as the original like Dioro Willy Mack video, right,
on Destiny. The >> Yeah. Because these people are scum.
Because people like Dior and Rob's media are total scum. Yeah.
Yeah. They will literally never go on stream and defend that
they do.
>> Oh, actually uh Rob's video is going to go on the halfbaked
podcast which is the Nicholas Dioro Turkey Tom and that guy.
>> Oh, nice. >> Talk with Yms. Yeah. For circle jerk.
You won't talk with Yms. So he told me I'm too busy to go on
your street power. I have to go on this circle jerk. That's why
that's why I DM
>> too busy going in the circle jerk. Uh anyway, uh Rob's
media I apologize for licking that but it was journalistic relevance.
Um, just like uh you showing YS's. So if you complain to your
>> there's a public interest.
>> There's a public interest. Just like showing YS's uh
horse uh furry avatar. There you go, >> dude. It wasn't
just the avatar. It was literally the first the first suit. >> Well,
yeah. Yeah, exactly. >> I assume it's Adam in that fursuit,
right? It's very >> It is. It is. Yeah. >> Very unsettling.
>> it's very Yeah, it's freaked up, but listen, some people
freak off, you know. It's okay.
What a waste of uh opportunity, you know. I'd debate why I mess
and win. I would be a virtuosist and win. That's what I would
do. Quinn is like a gay rule utilitarian. By the way, Jto, did
you know this? He's like a gay ruler
>> What does that mean?
>> Well, he basically said like, well, if um the outcome
is is like that,
>> where's the harm? Where's the harm? Where's the harm?
>> He says, well, if the outcome, it's like
>> Yeah. just the outcome. And he's like gay about it,
too. >> I'm going to be real. I think all of you guys need
God in your life. >> Um, you've said this already, >> but
have I told you that there reason >> Well, no on Twitter,
but I mean, you know, you sent I I read your Twitter. Is that
okay if I read your messages or >> No, my Twitter is my
like that's like non-judgmental. I'm harshly judging you. I'm
not saying this as a Christian. I'm saying this as a woman who's
repulsed by all three of you. Find Jesus. I mean that with like
disrespect, >> but like I mean when you say that I mean
do you mean it like >> you mean what? Spit it out in like
a >> Like in a nice or mean way? Like in a nice or mean
way? >> It depends how you're going to take it.
>> Do you think the rapture is today?
>> No, I'm not one of those.
>> Quan, you get the inside track on this. U today or yes,
no. >> Yeah, hope so.
>> I need to be free of the [__] Goyam. I need
I need to be free of the Goyam. Wait, don't I thought people
only people in the Holy Land get raptured? This would be a lot
of goam on Earth. >> That's facts. >> Don't you have
to be Don't you have to be in the Holy Land to get raptured?
>> That's facts. I need to get flight. >> It's true.
>> You don't go up, right? >> Stand there to
you don't go up. >> Just so you you mean you want to be
amongst all the Jews who get left behind, right? >> Um
yeah, I don't really know, but it's something be real. I'm I'm
>> the that's how Kyle Kolinsky argues that evangelical
Christians are are genocidal is because they want they want the
rapture to happen but they know that all the Jews get left behind
and so they want all the Jews to die in the >> is not like
a real
>> Yeah I know >> only knows about religion from
Darksiders 2. That's all knows about Catholicism is from Darksiders
2. >> Sure.
Honestly, I feel like he just has a big nose and he feels like
he just tells people
>> they won't make fun of his nose. >> Nobody could
really fight against it
>> It's true. He just like you like way a dog against it.
So >> like the
>> if you popped up on ethnoger, we could put you squarely
in Tel Aviv. That's the
>> Or maybe not. I can't even remember this. That's probably
less anti-semitic than putting you like in Germany, right? I
should put you like on I should put you in the home of the Khazars,
wherever that was, right? That's how I actually be anti-semitic,
I think.
>> Good job, J. >> Yeah, I'm not going to say my
ethnic background in terms of geography. That that might [__]
me somehow. Sorry.
>> you're British, right? What do you mean? Strange thing
to say. Would you speak with JTOK? Um, sorry. Would you speak
with Yms? JTOK. Do you watch Yms when you you grew up? Were you
groomed by YS? >> No. No, I don't know anything about Yms.
I've never watched >> But he would speak to Jayce. He would
speak to him about the Black Elves. You would absolutely speak
to >> Yeah, I talked to him about the Black >> No,
but like he asked you, "Would you speak to him?" And then he
asked if you watched him. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> What's
Yms's position on that? Do you >> I actually don't know.
>> Oh, black elves.
>> I feel like with those nails, he got to be pro black
now. Black elves. >> I Oh, by the way, on those nails,
I think this is not a joke. I've never seen him wear those nails
before. I'm pretty sure he's literally wearing those nails to
bait homophobic statements from >> protection as a shield.
>> No, no, not literally like to try and say, "Look, these
people are anti-LGBT."
Literally, that's what he's trying to >> They're attacking
me for being queer. >> I don't know if he's doing that
based that's based if he's saying that. >> Or or it's like
a BDSM thing. It's like his mask cuz he says he's submissive
in the video. So, it's like a humiliation fetish. That's gross.
So, it's either gross or based. If he's doing it to bait Nichols
Doro into being homophobic to try and destroy his career, that's
awesome. If he's doing it as some sort of humiliation ritual,
that's gay.
>> Well, he is gay. So, >> he's never worn them before,
right, Queenman? You were groomed, too, so you would know, right?
He's never worn them >> If only there was some indication
that he is both gay and into being humiliated. H
>> I watched I watch his yearly like best films or whatever
films he recommends that year, those videos.
>> And I watch um I watched like
>> I don't like the cool cat and stuff.
He could be one of those people where >> he just went to
a big event.
>> He just went to a big event and that's maybe the the
time where he would get his nails done and then it's like really
>> So then he just goes to TIFF. Yeah. >> Yeah. So
maybe he has nails done. >> He goes with his friends. Yeah.
Um >> Oh yeah. Wait, his American Old Boy review as well.
That what the US remake of Old Boy? I watch I watched that review.
Yeah, >> that's what I heard of Old Boys from that. That
was awesome. Did he give it better than like a two out of 10?
He
>> I can't I can't remember what he gave
>> Is better. Yeah. >> Yeah, it is.
>> That guy should be >> That guy should be locked
up. Spikeley should be locked up and like has cut, you know,
have a Tonka hat, but like for no particular reason. >> Okay.
It's actually a piece of filt.
Spike Lee or Yms?
>> Cherry. You ever watch a Spikeley movie? Ever watch
Spikeley movie? Cherry
>> I wouldn't know which ones did he do >> like a
bunch of black cult he was like he was like Tyler Perry before
he jango >> unchain he's like Tyler Perry existed he's
do the writing it's not do the writing it's do dah writing >> you
know cuz that's how your people speak according to this
uh race traitor I've never seen >> uh he made what else
does he make >> he makes like trash okay he makes like
>> very you ask your mom how much Tylenol she took while
she was pregnant with >> You made a Black Clansman. You
made Black Clansmen. >> Yeah, that sucked. That was a movie.
That was a decent movie. >> That sucked. It's like, >> wow.
Adam Ragusio says the says the Edward. Adam Reagio is the Edward.
Wow,
>> Cry. Cry. >> Why? Why I Why I Why I hard by Edward
and not my black person? That's >> That's a black clad.
>> There's no way.
>> Black clansman. That's about the black guy who was in
the police, right? Did I just Did I just totally >> Did
I just totally I don't even want to tell people what I did. >> What
did you do? >> You do. >> Okay. No, I didn't. No,
I didn't. No, I didn't. No, I didn't. No, I didn't. No, I didn't.
No, I didn't.
>> He made um Cherry. He made Crooklyn.
>> He made 25th Tower. He made Do We Sweep Blood of Jesus.
He made Malcolm X. He made Jungle. >> Well, I know that
I liked Black Clans, man. I did not watch Shyrack, but I know
a lot of people like that. >> Okay. Um
>> um he needs to be like
put in his place or something. I don't know. Um >> dude,
I don't go out to watch movies for the culture,
>> you know. Is really good.
>> Um go ahead. >> Watch every um every uh Jordan
Pale movie. He's not going to watch every >> um Did you
watch? >> She hasn't seen she hasn't seen
>> us. No, no, no. I haven't seen Nope. I haven't seen
>> us. Um
>> I only watched Django and like a couple weeks ago. >> Sorry
to bother you. >> That's a good one. Sorry to bother you.
It's like >> I still haven't seen Black Panther. >> Sorry
to bother you is a good movie. That was a good movie. >> I've
heard Sorry to Bother You.
>> never seen a thousand 100 Days of Slave or something.
>> He's really cool because he told me about all these
movies with nudity in them and those videos weren't age restricted
and so he deserves to have a YouTube channel. That's what I like
about YMS is that he like ruins kids by telling them about movies
with nudity. >> it sounds like this guy kind of won and
you're like totally raved. >> Well, he kind of did win
because I mean he got me into movies. So, I do appreciate that.
But also now I need to destroy him. >> It sounds like you're
more just like a fan than anything. >> A fallen fan. Maybe
a fallen fan like an >> No, it just sounds like you're
a fan. Just like you still enjoy his videos. I know he fell off
sincerely like ever since he started getting that editor because
if you don't know this guy his masai so he always complains about
how I'm going to get RSA one day my bones are going to break
but also he is like the most perfectionist editor so he spends
like a 100 hours on his videos and he cries he's like guys why
>> oh his furry editor right
>> no well he has a furry editor but I'm saying that yms
also edits his own videos and he does it in like the stupidest
most perfectionist way possible and then he cries and he's about
to get oh I'm going to get RSI Oh, my videos are so hard to make.
I'm going to need RSI. Yeah, do something to deal with it. Then
to solve the problem, but he cries about it. He has a video called
My Medical Problems where he talks about how because he takes
it up the ass, he has like a horrible like stomach condition.
This isn't a joke, by the way. It's called Health. >> Okay,
I don't think that's what does that to you.
>> Well, he says literally in the video that he has like
a him and his gay friends all have like this stomach condition.
I'm pretty sure
up and stuff for real. Listen, I don't mean in like a homophobic
way. >> Unlike gay people or like incontinent when they're
like old. >> Yeah, that's what I've heard like
>> this not Republican propaganda though.
>> Yeah, it might be totally homophobic.
>> Also, I think it's probably correct cuz here's the thing.
When it's Republican propaganda, gay people like hop up and they're
like, "No, that's factually incorrect." And >> you never
hear about that.
There's just no response. They just kind of like ignore it. I
know way more women who take it up the app. They don't have stomach
problems. >> Yeah, but they take it up. >> Yeah,
they probably take it up the app like once in a while. Not like
all the >> People as a hobby.
>> Well, compared to a necessity. Yeah, it's a hobby. >> I
don't know anything about gay culture in Please let me know more,
Perry. >> I feel like, listen, I can't say for sure cuz
I don't have the experience, but I think gay is way different
than heterero. I think it's like a totally different Yeah. is
like it's got to be like a Sounds homophobic. You >> just
mean like how they go about it or because of like the >> No,
I mean like how they go about it. I feel like how they I feel
like they they're just like >> drop of a hat kind of deal.
It's like >> you could never a woman would never let you
in the ass would let you in the
knew this. The Greeks knew this. I
>> Maybe it's cuz they're like fairies so like they have
like bad aim. Maybe it's cuz they're like fairies and like they
think they're going for the ass, but they're actually like [__]
you and the ribs and like breaks their stomach down bit by bit.
I don't know cuz like it's hard to see in those masks. >> I
feel like I don't want to I don't want to take any information
that you guys said today and like store it in my
I just want to make sure that I forget all of this and I don't
accidentally pull to any of these statements that you've said.
Like it's a memory of information that I've confirmed or
>> Like the rapture is today, so it should be pretty easy
to like forget. I mean, I don't know. It's like short term. >> Oh
my god. Oh, wait. It is the 23rd. It's that you were talking
about with the cow in China. >> Yeah, the red heer. >> No,
in Judea. >> Oh, Judea. Where does China come into >> Let's
go.
>> I don't think China comes into this.
>> They have their own Israel in China. Like um sort of
like, you know, like uh freckles. It's like China has like a
freckle Israel, you know. >> They do. Okay. Well, what's
going to happen when the heer bleeds? >> I don't know.
The world ends or I don't know something
that's who cares. The thes are doing too well to let the game
end right now. Okay. They're on top of the world. You think they're
going to let the Do you think they're going to let the apocalypse
happen while they're running everything? I don't think so. I
they they got to be knocked down a peg before that happens. Okay,
>> there's one thing I've learned is it's always bet on
the coming out on top. Okay, there's one thing one thing I've
learned. Power is forever.
>> If it was really forever, why would Nick Fuentes put
out an interview for tomorrow if he knew it was going to be the
end of the world? >> He would have done it yesterday, right?
>> Wall reference. It's like a fourth wall reference, you
know? It's like, well, that just happened. Hey guys, oh, I'm
going to stop dying tomorrow. But it's like you died today. You
know, like you know what I mean? >> Gotcha. Yay. Knew.
Did he Did you guys react to Dave Blunts
trying to take on
>> Yeah, that was awesome. Did you Did you watch uh the
the baby music video?
>> Yeah, we watch. >> Oh, wait. We had this conversation.
>> Yeah. Yeah, >> that's awesome.
>> That is not awesome. >> The catching of the knife
is pretty
>> They bailed out. They bailed out the killer for that
video. That's like really impressive. If no one talks about how
ending cash bail is important so you can guess the guy that stabbed
the lady on your music video.
>> Shut the [__] up. >> Is that what
you would say? >> Based on a true story. >> Shut
up.
>> Yeah. I got to say just Rob's I've got a special distaste
for people like Rob's media who just can't can't just come out
and make like actually political videos. Instead guys it in this
like wretched way. In fact, this his Denim's videos are like
[__] Jesus Christ. >> Uh what's his name? YMS
does explicitly call that out. He's like this guy is just going
after like he said something and then he's like and then like
vaguely like left-leaning content creators like he's just hit
pieces on them reading their Kiwi Farms threads. It's like Kiwi
Farms threads and lefting content creators and like some other
thing. He's
it's just for not standing on it. It's >> cuz you just
know he's sort of
>> Yeah. not not debating making well making political
videos and being obviously a sort of person
they're not political videos I'm just doing that is like you
know lazy content creator I made 15 videos >> it's just
like it's just like a whole video about how suck isn't real work
it's like I'm not political though I'm not a political
>> oh you guys have watched some of the Denim's videos
or is Denim's videos good >> no they're [__]
awful from what I've >> well that's what I mean but are
they funny to watch through and just laugh at >> no Rob's
media videos >> they're like boring There's not even >> really
boring.
>> No,
I don't even like literally don't even a log this guy. I don't
watch this guy's videos cuz they suck and his voice sucks and
he's gay. >> Like Chud hired this guy. If you don't know
JTO the Lord, Chud like has a contract with Rob's Media where
he like pays him $200 a month to make videos and Chud gets access
and Chud doesn't even use him anymore. He just like uses Lord
Crust instead because this Rob's media guys videos are so [__]
He's like in a deal. Ch has to pay this guy $200 a month for
the rest of his life. literally just made all of his stuff. >> Why
did you make this? >> So, explain why Ches videos. >> Why
does Ch watch all this guy's videos then? If that what I'm saying,
>> videos watched. >> All of them. Every single one.
The YMS one, the Denims one, the other Denims one, the other
Denims one, the one. >> Wait, is he has he actually watched
all the Denims on? >> Wait, has he actually watched all
the Denims ones? >> He's watched. >> Yeah, I think
he's watched most videos. >> Wait, I thought I thought
he didn't like >> That stuff. Yeah. >> Oh, I see.
But this is like lazy reactant, you know, this like lazy reactant.
But like it was a bad deal cuz the videos are so [__]
So now Chad has to hire other people like Lord Crust. He obviously
Liquid Sonic is like $1,000 a month that he pays for other people
to make him free content. >> That actually just because
you said Lord just reminded me, Queenie, you saw that the Lord
Miles thing was like probably fake, right? >> I I don't
even know for sure, but >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I know.
>> It was funny that it was like, yeah, he's probably not
dead. It's probably just them manipulating the market. Uh coin
work crypto though. >> Oh, well it's not a it's not like
a Yeah, it's it's just a Yeah, it's like a prediction market
if there's a cryptocoin backing it. So you just like crash the
market down to no nothing
>> buy it. Yep. Yep. >> Oh man, you guys
>> see Trump not knowing how to pronounce acetaminophen
today. Acetaminophen. That's a tricky word. >> That's a
tough one. That is a tough one.
So it's just like a study that like Tylenol when you're in pregnant
>> immediately the FD >> uh like it's a study but
apparently apparently like there the data is bad and it's probably
not actually like a tangible like >> I was thinking I mean
like I'm sure that in modernity more people take painkillers
so you're just going to see a correlation and I'm sure that Trump
and his fascist regime are so >> that they would like mix
up a basic science point like that.
Yeah, that's basically what a lot of people are saying is they
they essentially have like other studies that show it's okay,
but they ignored all of those studies and just looked at the
one study where it said they said it was not okay. Yeah, this
is a >> VA will be notifying physicians that the use of
>> said well let's see how we say that >> what if
he didn't do this advertis
what's going to take him down is going >> stomp this guy
>> take autism dude there are people who are going to start
taking ad not aderall they're going to start taking uh telenol
more because Trump said not to you know there are just defiantes
out there defiant leftist Wait, wait, wait, wait. >> Do
you guys know anybody who's like had their livers get boxed from
or their liver get boxed from Tylenol toxicity? Like acetaminophen
toxicity? Maybe that's just a myth to prevent you from developing
like >> superhuman autism powers. Maybe that's like the
secrets of autism. >> Don't do this at home. >> Does
House MD did House MD not take Vive Ants every day? That's what
I heard. >> I mean, I saw the show. I heard I watch I heard
the >> Yeah, he take No, he takes um Vivants. >> we're
not on the other V drug. Not the other V drug, not Vant. Sorry.
>> Vicodin. Yeah, >> Vikin. Okay. Okay. >> See,
Cman knows cuz he's a Destiny fan. Like Queen's never seen House.
He just knows it from Destiny. >> You could just see a
house.
I actually know someone who likes House IRL. That's where I know
it from. I >> His name's Steven Benell.
Freak. JTO. Um, what do you think of Plastic Peach?
>> Don't no idea what you're talking about. >> Plastic
what? >> What do you think of the gorillas? Would you go
concert with um with with me. You would go to your list concert
with me. >> I don't even know what that is. >> The
cartoon >> right now, man. >> Yeah. I don't know
what that is. >> VTubers. It's like the OG Vtuber band.
You know, Iron Mouse. It's like Iron >> Yeah, I know. Iron
Mouse. Iron Mouse. >> Iron Mouse [__] >> It's
like Iron Mouse. Yeah.
>> Go try to snatch her oxygen away from her so she so
she hyperventilates on >> Yeah. And there's one called
Noodle, and she's like the the petite Lolita character, but now
she's of age because we moved past that stage in society. >> And
then there's also a um
>> there's a fat black guy, the Stylo of the group. He
actually made a song Stylo. Um and then there's like an evil
guy. He's he's evil, but he's pro Palestine. Did you hear about
this? >> Have you watched that performance yet? Have you
watched the performance from that fundraiser? >> I saw
the picture. I just saw the picture. We were we were making jokes
at your expense by your terrible takes on >> about my correct
takes about plastic beach that you can't handle. >> It's
it's hilarious that you think like literally any% >> filler
which is correct. That's that take. You mean >> he was
saying gorillas? There's no way he was saying gorillas there.
>> He said
obviously I know feel good inc. Sorry. I I literally my headphones
are clicking. I know exactly what you're talking >> It
was it >> girls. I bet you're saying girls cuz it was clicking.
>> I Yeah.
>> that's your headphones.
>> Sure, man. >> Speech
freaking
>> Okay. I didn't buy parker. Yeah, but I bought a cheaper
one.
>> I took myself down.
>> Good job, man. Proud of you. >> What else do you
think about Perry?
What do you mean? >> a lot of stuff like uh >> what
are you thinking about? >> I was thinking about >> Well,
I mean like when I woke up I was thinking about oh man I wonder
what I should like have for breakfast but I didn't finish that
thought and then yesterday I was >> Did you have breakfast
today?
>> Wait the hypothetical. Never mind. Go
>> So yeah, I was thinking about like this like Minecraft
build I was trying to make. It's like going to be like a cool
castle, but I don't think I'm going to do it cuz the server has
like dumb settings. And then I was like, um, what content is
there today? That's what I was thinking. Oh, did you hear about
the Godzilla stuff? I was thinking about power scaling.
>> Scaling age restricting your Minecraft server. Or is
that still a problem?
>> No, that's I lost the Minecraft server because the uh
because Paragon Star >> Yeah, Paragon. Yeah. Yeah. >> Had
the whole ordeal, you know. >> That guy is still around,
right? That guy's like uh >> Oh, yeah. >> I feel
like is that guy going around like posting AI clips of everybody
now? Um, I think it's him, but people say it's not him based
for some reason. But there the guy the guy that posted the AI
clips is Denal. Um,
>> And people are afraid to say his name. Like um, like
you know Dickers was afraid to say his name. It's very
>> I think people are afraid to say his name. I think they
just don't I think they just don't give him attention because
it's best not give people that >> J Stark. Yeah. J St.
>> What are you thinking, man? >> I don't I super
don't care. Oh, >> he can I'll I'll listen. If he does
10 more AI videos under my tweets, I'll give him like another
shout out. Okay. >> I mean, if you're um if you're already
botting, I guess, you know, it's uh water of a ducks back. E
>> on Twitter, I'm botting on on kick. Whatever. Um >> Oh,
great point. Great point, Barry. Totally winning. >> I
don't Why this isn't a fight, man. I just want to hang. I just
listen. I mean, did you ask me what I think about? I told about
Minecraft. And did you see the Godzilla drama? That stuff's crazy,
>> What's the Godzilla drama, Perry? >> Um, there's
these two, like there's this guy with 7,000 subscribers called
KOTM, this king of the monsters, and he like [__]
is getting attacked by like this Birdman guy who's like 300K.
Like, this guy is evil. This guy's evil cuz he said he said,
and it's like that's based, but then they were like, he said
he said yourself in your bloodline to like a minor. And then
it's like, yeah. though. It was awesome. But they're like spuring
out over him. >> Yeah, that's boring.
>> No, you don't get it. Okay, because you're whatever.
You're just like too busy about politics. You You can't enjoy
the finer things in life, >> dude. Just I don't know how
you can cover like these gay TF2 community drama. Godzilla community
drama. >> I didn't cover I didn't cover TF2 drama. I made
that into drama to be clear. the Godzilla stuff. I was taking
a a chance and it's ended up being really really interesting
and um
like what do you want me to what like what I'm trying to branch
out here man branch out here. What's your problem? >> I've
seen this exact tweet like a thousand times now. >> How
many how many instances of this watch your husband just got shot
in the
That's awesome. >> I've seen this tweet a thousand different
ways though. I've seen it a thousand different ways with like
every
>> pop off entry. >> That's a genre. >> I've
seen it with all of them. You guys saw Trump's Little Dance at
the end,
>> Yeah, it was awesome. It's hilarious. >> Oh, look.
It's literally It's literally every a bunch of them. >> I
think it's beautiful that like um Donald Trump made Charlie Kirk
set all about himself. It's what Charlie would have wanted. He's
honoring his memory. >> Yeah, he just turned it into a
political rally. Good times. Good times. >> So brave. Very
brave of him. >> Very cool. What a hero. Sigh. Did you
hear Jimmy came back? Are you going to co-host the Jimmy Kimmel
show? >> Jimmy's free. They freed Jimmy. Jimmy wasn't free.
Now he's free. >> Answering my question. Not even answering
my question. You I don't think you would. I don't think you would
co-host the Jimmy Kimmel show. I think you're like a mate's coward.
>> Uh,
all right. >> There you go. >> There you go. >> All
right. I'm uh I finally just caught back up. >> Okay, you
finish. You go. I was going to say, how does it feel knowing
that Plastic Beach has less filler than like any one of your
streams?
>> Um, you could say that about your streams, but on mine.
My streams are like Kino wallto-wall kino like >> they're
not. They're definitely not. >> Name one problem with my
stream. Like you always say, >> you sat there playing Minecraft
for the last two days for most of the stream. >> I didn't
play any Minecraft yesterday. I played I used I did a Minecraft
segment yesterday. That's what I did. You're mixing it up more
on What is a Minecraft segment? You mean you sat there playing
Minecraft on stream? No, >> I sped out about some guy's
Minecraft gameplay change ideas. It's got a Minecraft balance
update and I called him a mongaloid. He is he is a mong for that.
He was like such a piece of [__] I mean, you're just
like, you know, I mean, you really don't help yourself when you
act like depressed and when people say you have depression. So,
you can't even
enjoy the Godzilla drama. It's like a really good drama, man.
>> All right, any final thoughts, guys? Any final thoughts?
>> didn't think so. All right. Nope.
>> Okay. All right. >> Probably going to try to utilize
uh not utilize, but just go in Discord voice chat before stream.
Maybe sometimes after stream to watch some of the content that
I don't think we would just like mindlessly watch on stream to
see if there's something worth it. >> Oh, sure. So like
every aerodite video
>> maybe mindfulness training >> watching Hutch are
doing >> mindfulness right now Jerry
>> mindfulness right now >> probably giving me a
>> what the [__] are you talking about
>> no because you're
mindfully meditating
>> more yeah >> no it's like an open invitation to
watch party in a voice channel
>> no I said you were talking to like Jay talk though cuz
you're like talking like >> no he knows he knows I want
to do in that to the audience.
>> You're going to do like you're going to
>> stream back when I used to be on the stream more often.
>> I was there. I used to see your streams where you did
like those. >> No, not my strict.
>> This guy hears like three words out of somebody's mouth
and he starts ripping up whatever whatever [__] that
goes into. It's crazy. >> This guy responds to sentences.
That's >> I meant >> But you don't respond to sentences
said. You respond to like half a sentence and then assume the
rest of it. Well, it should be obvious what the sentence is if
it's a well- constructed sentence, but whatever. >> So,
back when I stream with J- Sock, when I used to be on stream
more often, I would sometimes go in the Discord to watch videos
or we would have or call afterwards and stuff like that. We're
trying to figure out a way to get back into it. I was going to
do watching going to do watching the Lion King, but then it realized
everyone's going to be gripping to it because of the YMS furry.
>> Yeah. So guys,
you don't do those
>> Uh, just haven't been doing them. Haven't had content
for it, but there's a lot of Nick Fentes content coming out.
So, might start doing some of that. >> Okay. So, I can
still criticize you. Good. I can still criticize you for that.
That's good. >> Have you seen that stuff where apparently
Nick's are starting to turn the Griff?
>> No, but I mean it it makes sense to be honest. It's
a
I don't see that he's saying he lally outright said he wants
to marry uh white nationalism and liberalism.
It's like how do you even do that? How how does Nick's world
how does
change his worldview in such a way that it's palatable to both
ethnationalists and moderate liberals? >> I mean if they
remove
>> they remove the religiosity from it. >> Yeah.
There can't be any enforced religion and that you have to allow
like free speech and there's like so many concessions you have
to make. I just don't know how he makes those. >> You would
just say that like um Catholicism or Christianity is so superior
went out in the free marketplace of ideas. >> He could
say, but I don't know how he says that with his previous ideology.
>> Porterellar Porterellar points out that this is just
Richard Spencer's whole thing Apolloism and Richard Spencer's
already trying to do that and failing basically. Everybody hates
him. >> Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. It doesn't work for
Richard Spencer. That's what I mean, right? Not >> you
don't get the idea. >> Richard Spencer is not funny enough.
>> Richard Spencer is not funny enough to make like that
work. He's like he's not and he could come up with a honestly
Nick might just go read whatever Richard Spencer's written and
then just make it funny and then >> I think you have to
be >> I mean I feel like the selling point of >> liberalism
the the selling point of Richard Spencer is just sort of like
um
he's almost like convenient for libs to prop up because it's
like um >> you mean like stories a lot of his a lot of
his rhetoric around it is is just basically like, "Oh, well,
libs are the only people who are capable of running a country
and I don't want white people to live in country." That's basically,
you know, when I've seen him talk about it on Twitter, how he
tries to sell it to people. I feel like that kind of works, but
I don't know how you take it past >> Andrew Tate just hit
$5. >> A good one, Brav.
>> I'm pretty sure you do. I think uh Oh, donation. Thank
you. Thank you, Andrew Tate. Thank you very much. Um, I'm pretty
sure if you have any sort of feeling of uh like Christian morality,
any religion guiding you into believing that is how you should
live your life, you reject liberalism. You reject that there
are multiple ways that people can live their life in harmony,
right? You subscribe to one style. You you oppose autonomy for
your theology.
No, not theology for your >> the right way for us in order.
>> You mean you mean the reason why the reason why you
allow for liberal freedoms is because your Christian worldview
means that
you you have to like you can't take that away from the
>> Is that what you're saying? um you would be you would
be uh you'd be lying to yourself and to others if you pretended
like people aren't doing harm by living their life off the the
path of >> well but couldn't you understand the
to find their best way in life right the harm is a necessary
element of God giving us free will in order for us to find a
way that we can you know fit within God's plan so to speak so
I don't think necessarily that you would need to have a some
sort of like Catholic
liberal ism is the best way for people to live Christ through
their actions,
>> No. No. >> Well, you could believe that without
>> power. Okay. >> I'm just like the argument there
is
with without theonomy that people left to their own devices will
be
>> Yeah. But why make that argument? >> So that's
why you generally won't have those two positions married, >> right?
But then simply you would not have that position. You have the
position that like people up to their own vices are best able
to find you know God's you know path for them and as we should
give people freedom cuz that's what you know that's why God gave
us free will or whatever and so he will allow us to you know
uh do what you know
no you can believe in a religion without feeling like you have
to be ruled by
like the moralities of that religion
>> is that I don't I don't think we're seeing different
you can be ruled by the moralities but no but you're saying that
if somebody was truly to be a religious person and you know direct
political worldview from that. So that they would have to believe
it's some sort of autocracy, you know, to do with like aonomy
where it's like the societal norms are based on religion. But
couldn't you also believe that like due to like your religious
fates that you think that it should be a liberal society so as
to allow people to explore, you know, to to be confronted by
vices but then overcome them. Couldn't you believe that as well?
>> I'm saying I don't believe you could. You either don't
understand what you believe or you are contradicting your own
belief
to serve a purpose of more power. I don't understand. You're
saying you found a week ago >> saying in order to hold
two opposing ideologies
is either there's two reasons for it in my opinion. I could be
missing one is you either don't realize that you don't have any
idea of what you're saying or you're more interested in power
so you're willing to marry two
>> ideologies because you think you're just going to get
more support and get further in your political aspirations.
You're insinuating that it is opposing to like you know somebody
who believes in Christ for them to see the world as you know
being some
that I said that shut up Perry you not a serious person I'm about
to have this conversation with
>> argue with like when people say that like British Oh
my god if you're just going to
I I try to figure out
what you're saying it seems to be like you're saying >> I
know it seems like you're hearing something I'm not saying Let
me ask Let me ask you then. Are you saying that How about you
don't ask? >> Believe in some sort of authoritarian >> How
about you don't ask? Are >> you saying that for somebody
to be Christian, they would have to be a subway authoritarian?
Is that what you're saying? Is that what you're >> No,
I never said authoritarian this entire time. >> So So yeah,
but when you say what I said authoritarian, isn't it? Yeah, but
the >> I'm saying what the I said and the moment you can
say it back to me is the time I will start taking you seriously.
>> You said that's >> what is a Maltese? That's a
breed of a
memeing out of it. Memeing out that you're actually meing out.
Is this all like a grift for you? Is this
You've got to admit, you've got to admit you're a sword.
You've got
>> I would never deny I would never deny it. I used to
deny it. I don't deny it anymore. I'm just astounded that like
Cherry is like springing out about this. >> I
didn't conversation, but I listened to enough to know Perry only
listened to the first three words of any sentence Cherry said,
so he probably doesn't understand her. >> Well, I only
need the three words. I only need the three words. The word started
with Christians are authoritarian and that's just not true. >> I
didn't say those three words. I actually specifically >> said
Christians should be pushing. >> I actually specifically
didn't. >> Well, then what did you say? >> Get back
to me. When you go through the VOD and you write down what I
said. >> Not my job to educate you. Not my job to educate
you. Okay. Okay. >> I'm not educating you. It's not my
job to repeat the same five, six, seven times. You got the attention
span of a goldfish. Your mom clearly was taking Tylenol all through
your pregnancy. >> No, only only
>> Well, listen. You know, Cherry, you know, the problem
is
>> I I'm being guru to you. I'm sorry. >> Wow. What
an awesome moment to end on. Guys, thanks for watching. >> Hold
on. >> Thank you. >> We're going to go over to Listen,
if you guys want to keep listening to Quean and Perry talk, reach
over to Perry's channel. Okay.
I I Wait, I have Rey's avatar in reactive Discord. What the [__]
>> Sorry, I'm looking at
I don't know what that's about. >> It's cuz I I was using
it for the FBI thing. I didn't want to set it to the same avatars.
I didn't even realize that set to that. All right. Okay, guys.
I'm hosting Perry. >> Good eater. I just >> go to
sleep >> till you face.
>> Have a good stream, Perry, and have a good night, everybody
else. Be back
>> Very kind of you. Reject reject. I'm rejecting the raid
to me though on my own screen. >> Hold on.